[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Olivier
nous pour le groupe de l'Union centriste
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers
sans contenu c'est force et faiblesses
je souhaite souligner sa forte portée
symbolique je le dis sans réserve la
qualité de nos débats sans être d'accord
surtout bien sûr entre les groupes mais
aussi avec les ministres au nord la
République d'ailleurs sur le terrain
dans l'opinion et même dans la sphère
médiatique les éloges sur nos travaux
fleurissent entendez-vous les mêmes
remarques que moi mes chers collègues
les débats au Sénats sont plus
intéressants à suivre que ceux de
l'Assemblée nationale vous travaillez
bien au Sénat heureusement qu'il y a le
Sénat et bien ces remarques ne sont pas
le fruit du hasard elles sont fondées
elles sont même méritées le débat sur le
plfs c'est l'occasion de souligner la
place le rôle et la responsabilité du
Sénat au moment même au moment précis où
le cocktail majorité relative et groupe
extrémiste et populiste puissant
fragilise l'Assemblée nationale
oui mes chers collègues c'est le moment
du Sénat la majorité sénatoriale est
parfaitement à la hauteur de ses
responsabilités et permettez-moi de le
constater le groupe Union centriste avec
son président Hervé Marseille qui a lui
aussi toute sa place dans cette période
si particulière je peux témoigner comme
chef de fil du groupe Union centriste
sur ce PLFSS que le Sénat trouvait toute
sa place dans le monde post dans le
monde parlementaire post cumule et poste
loi confiance 2017 c'est vrai que celles
et ceux qui emprunté la dialectique du
nouveau monde pour nous ringardiser ou
même justifié en chuchotant notre
disparition programmée sont les premiers
maintenant inventés nos mérites prenons
ce bénéfice chers collègues les
sénateurs ne se contentent pas comme je
l'ai parfois entendu de manière
pernicieuse à l'époque de rencontrer les
maires comme les visiteurs médicaux
rencontrent autrefois les médecins non
les sénateurs ne se contentent pas de
faire des relations publiques auprès des
élus pour assurer leur élection bien sûr
les sénatrices et les sénateurs
représentent les territoires les
collectivités territoriales et au
premier rang les hussards de la
République que sont les mers ils sont
mieux que cela des législateurs à part
entière qui font la loi animé par
l'intérêt général et le bien commun et
pour preuve si certains regardent
parfois de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
pour justifier une modification de notre
Constitution nous sénateurs nous ne
devons pas regarder vers les USA pour
trouver des arguments en faveur du
bicamérisme ces arguments ces fondements
on les trouve ici et maintenant
Pardonnez ce propos peut-être un peu
long mais je l'avais sur le cœur à
présent je souhaite mettre en avant le
travail de la commission des affaires
sociales en particulier celui qui a été
accompli par sa présidente Catherine de
roche et la rapporteur général Elisabeth
Doisneau j'avais salué l'année dernière
votre première fois réussie madame la
rapporteur général la seconde fut aussi
de très bonnes factures vous accordez
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
une importance particulière à une
meilleure prévention avec la mise en
place de rendez-vous de prévention ce
que nous saluons mais dans le même temps
nous considérons avec Jocelyne guides
qu'il s'agit d'une mise de départ et que
la prévention ne peut s'arrêter à trois
rendez-vous dans la vie d'une personne
vous donnez la priorité au vieillir à
domicile le virage domiciliaire est une
priorité nous le soutenons mais en
l'espèce les moyens d'accompagnement
tels que l'appât ne sont plus
soutenables par les départements nous
appelons de nos vœux avec Valérie
léthard une réforme des concours de la
CNSA en attendant le Sénat l'initiative
du groupe centriste adoptait un
amendement permettant une mise en œuvre
accélérée de deux heures de temps social
au bénéfice tant des personnes des sad
que des personnes bénéficiaires de la
part surtout cet amendement permet de
limiter la part de dépenses APA à la
charge des départements sur cette
question comme sur beaucoup d'autres il
n'est plus acceptable que l'État décide
et que les collectivités locales et
territoriales se contente de payer ou
doit se contenter de payer sur le volet
familial la décision du gouvernement de
refuser de revaloriser de moitié
l'allocation du soutien familiale en
faveur des parents isolés et l'une des
rares lueurs de ce bel FSS pour la
branche famille pour le reste le
transfert à la CNAF de la charge des
indemnités journalières du congé
postnatal de maternité était une mesure
qui ne trouvait aucune justification
elle démontre tout simplement le manque
d'ambition du gouvernement en matière de
politique familiale et le refus de
revenir à l'universalité des allocations
familiales qui passent par la
suppression de leur modulation pour nous
la politique familiale n'est pas une
politique sociale c'est une politique
familiale il convient d'ailleurs de
s'atteler à la création de place de
crèche nous en avons parlé ensemble
monsieur le ministre c'est une attente
des familles mais aussi une mesure
indispensable pour assurer l'égalité
homme-femme et accroître l'employabilité
enfin je vase tester sur insister sur
deux mesures qui améliorent grandement
ce PLFSS l'annulation du transfert à
l'URSSAF des cotisations de retraite
complémentaires de la jko la défense du
paritarisme et dans l'ADN du groupe
Union centriste et de la majorité
sénatoriale nous sommes les défenseurs
du dialogue social pas par dogmatisme
mais parce que les retraites agir sont
bien gérés par les partenaires sociaux
autre mesure importante celle sur les
retraites elles démontrent notre volonté
de préserver le modèle français
redistributif en maîtrisant la part des
redistributions sociales
je veux pour conclure aborder une autre
question qui me tient à cœur notre
système de santé est en train de craquer
je le dis au fort haut et fort il
souffre au moins autant du manque de
moyens que de la sur administration ou
la Surb bureaucratisation un mal bien
français je prendrai un dernier exemple
conscient de la pénurie de médecins dans
notre pays nous avons voté à l'unanimité
la fin du numerus clausus
malheureusement les conséquences de
cette décision sont décevantes et se
font attendre nous n'avons formé que de
13% de médecins en plus nous allons
former que
13%, 13% c'est ridicule la fautaki
l'administration le Conseil de l'Ordre
les doyen des facultés peu importe mais
une chose est sûre on ne peut pas en
rester là
sous peine de voir la pénurie de
médecins d'aujourd'hui s'aggraver demain
et après-demain le système est à ce
point absurde que nos étudiants les plus
brillants se trouvent contraint de se
former en Roumanie pour revenir à la fin
de leurs études exercées en France
comment comprendre qu'un grand pays
comme la France serait moins capable que
la Roumanie ou d'autres pays de faire
évoluer dans l'intérêt de tous son
système de formation mes chers collègues
le groupe UC votera ce plfs mais nous
voulions travers de cette intervention
témoigner de la fragilité de notre
système de santé et de l'urgence de
débattre d'une grande loi santé je vous
remercie
merci
[Applaudissements]
venez maintenant